i've learned that you have to become  successful at success  and it's a different kind of discipline  in fact the antidote to the  undisciplined pursuit of more is the  disciplined pursuit of less  but better  and what we've learned is that as we try  to teach this to people first of all  they just can't do it  just life is just so far so consuming  with the non-essential this is the  culture of our times and so we created a  program a one-year executive development  program for slow growth  because we know that's what it really  takes a process to change there's lots  to talk about mindset today to change  the mindset  from you know everything that everyone's  doing everything popular now to the  right things at the right time for the  right reasons